of my colleagues that continue to tell
me that do not want a condition to Aid
they give it to a genocidal maniac my
message to those col my colleagues is
simple if you don't support Netanyahu if
you're disgusted by the countless videos
of lifeless children pulled out of the
rubble if you actually believe in
upholding human rights and international
law vote no on a blank check to
netanyahu's genocide g l time expired
thank you Gentle lady from Connecticut
reserves gentlemen from California is
recognized
I would say the folks that believe in
genocide is Hamas I yield to the
gentleman from Florida the chairman of
the state and foreign operations
subcommittee Mr Dez Ballard two and a
half minutes gentleman's recognized Mr
speaker thank you let me first thank the
gentleman uh from California chairman
Calbert for his leadership and drafting
this critical Bill along with the
chairwoman K Granger and the leadership
for bringing this
forward as Mr Calbert just said yes
there has been genocide but the genocide
has been
from Hamas from Hamas and if the world
needed yet another reminder of the
importance of of Israel as a safe haven
for the Jewish people then the the
attacks of October 7th should be that
wakeup call this is not that complicated
I've been disgusted and shocked by some
of the things that we've been hearing
including the sheer Glee and displayed
in celebration across even in this
country um because of the the murders of
October and remember those grotesque
celebrations and demonstrations happened
before Israel even began its military
action to defend Israelis uh again in
Gaza so let's be clear those
demonstrations those statements those
celebrations were were and are in favor
of the terrorist group
Hamas the Despicable anti-Semitism which
has been dramatically increased since
October 7th that we've even seen here
sometimes times on this floor has to be
con uh condemned and has to stop Israel
is on the front line in the battle
against terrorism the terrorism of Hamas
Hezbollah Isis you name it uh and all of
those they continue to await for an
opportunity to strike at Israel as they
have just like they want to strike here
to the the American people in the United
States Israel and the United States do
not want
violence but the problem is that the
terrorists do and they are the ones who
have killed and butchered and maimed
innocent Israelis again last November
the house passed another Israel Security
Supplemental which was fully offset by a
resis recision of the IRS funding and
that was the reason why the White House
claimed that they opposed that bill well
now there are zero excuses to oppose
this bill this bill does one thing Mr
Speaker it provides urgently needed
funding for our friend and Ally Israel
to defeat the terrorists that they are
dealing with the United States must
stand with Israel and to eradicate
terrorism this is not that complicated
you can use every excuse in the world to
then and again with a purpose of
supporting Hamas and justifying the
murderers this bill stands with Israel
no is no ants no buts I'm grateful for
chair to Chairman Calbert for bringing
this important piece of legislation and
I wholeheartedly support I yield back
gentleman from California reserves G
lady from Connecticut's recognized Mr
Speaker I yield one minute to the
general woman from California the
distinguished ranking member of the
state and foreign operations
subcommittee Miss Lee gent ladies
recognized thank you very much I want to
thank the gentle lady for yielding and
for her um strong strong leadership Mr
Speaker I Rise to oppose HR 7217 the
United States and the world are facing a
very dangerous time with the risk of
being pulled deep deeper and deeper into
conflicts across the globe meanwhile
millions of people around the world are
facing violence dislocation and hunger
this bill really is not a serious effort
as the ranking member of the state and
foreign operation subcommittee I cannot
support a bill that fails to meet the
challenges of this moment and abandons
those most in need of humanitarian
assistance and yes this this bill
undermines the United States policy
which supports a two-state solution this
bill is a blatant political stunt that
is Dead on Arrival in the Senate and so
I urge my colleagues to oppose it thank
you and I yield the balance of my time
gentle lady from Connecticut reserves
yes gentleman from California is
recognized may I uh inquire how much
time is
left both sides gentleman from
California has 30
seconds lady from Cali Connecticut has
two
minutes uh Mr Speaker who has the right
to close reserve the right to close G
from
Connecticut I'm prepared to close J from
California reserves G from Connecticut
is recognized okay thank
you a short while ago my colleague from
Arkansas said it is our solemn duty to
protect our allies indeed it is our
solemn duty to protect our allies our
allies in this case are isra yes and we
support Israel our Ally is Ukraine and
we need to continue to support Ukraine
our Ally is Taiwan and we need to
support Taiwan we have a solemn Duty yes
to provide humanitarian assistance to
innocent civilians we have a solemn duty
to protect our border these are not the
issues that are part of this bill this
bill does not meet those solemn
obligations my Republican colleagues do
not want to help Ukraine or the Indo
Pacific in Taiwan they do not want to
address border security it is a they
talked about border security as being
the key to opening up the door to
foreign assistance they said it in the
White House the speaker did that and now
has walked away from it it is really a
political shame they are they do not
want to um promote humanitarian
assistance and
leave millions of innocent civilians
without food shelter clothing in a
conversation with a director of the
world food organization uh uh uh uh
Cynthia McCain she said and I asked
about Gaza she said to me Rosa these
people are starving it is a famine and I
believe that is as well in this process
of providing assistance to just Israel
and not our other allies they do hurt is
Israel and isolate Israel it is time for
my colleagues to be able to on the other
side of the aisle to put our country and
our national security ahead of partisan
politics what we should do is to vote
this bill down I yield back gent lady
from Conneticut yields gentlemen from
California is recognized G lady yelds
the balance for time yes
sir I'll close uh the gentle lady is
correct this bill is not about Ukraine
or Indo pay or some other things that uh
that I would love to have some
discussions about in the future this is
about Israel and I think my friends on
the other side of the aisle know I'm not
a cynical person I uh I went about this
I've been in favor of moving an Israel
bill for some time and now is the
time uh I uh I think it's just simply
the right thing to do and with that
let's pass this bill let's support
Israel and I yield back to balance of my
yields the question is will the house
suspend the rules and pass the Bill HR
7217 those in favor say
I those opposed no in the opinion of the
chair 2third being the affirmative the
rules are suspended the bill is passed
without objection the motion to
reconsider is Mr Speaker pures a g lady
from connetic for the Y and
nays the Y and nays are requested those
favoring a vote by the Y and nays will
rise a significant a sufficient number
having risen the yays and nays are
ordered pursuant to Clause 8 of rule 20
further proceedings on this question are
postponed proceedings will resume on
questions previously postponed votes
will votes will be taken in the
following order the motion to suspend
the rules and pass HR 1727 if ordered
adoption of house resolution 863 if
ordered and the motion to suspend the
rules and pass HR
7217 the first electronic vote will be
conducted as a 15minute vote pursuant to
Clause 9 of rule 20 remaining electronic
votes will be conducted as five minute
votes pursuant to Clause 8 of rule 20
the unfinished business is the question
on suspending the rules and passing hr1
1727 as amended which the clerk will
report by title Union calendar number
297 hr1
1727 a bill to amend the Chesapeake and
Ohio Canal development act to extend the
Chesapeake and Ohio Canal National
Historical Park
commission the question is will the
house suspend the rules and pass the
bill as
amended so many as are in favor say I
those oppose
no in the opinion of the chair
two-thirds being in the affirmative the
bills are sus the rules are
suspended for what purposes the
gentleman from California secret Mr
Speaker I demanded the A and
A the A and A are requested those
favoring a vote by the Y and nays will
rise a sufficient number number having
risen the Ys and nays are ordered
members will record their votes by
electronic device this is a 15minute
vote
for
e
I
what
e
for
[Music]
e
he
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
for
e
all members
loaded does any M to
on this vote the Y's are 427 the Nays
are two 2/3 being in the affirmative the
rules are suspended the bill is passed
and while without objection the motion
to reconsider consider is laid on the
table pursuant to Clause 1 C of rule 19
further consideration of house
resolution 863 will now resume the clerk
will report the
title house calend number 60 house
resolution
863 resolution impeaching Alejandro
Nicholas maoris Secretary of Homeland
Security for high crimes and
misdemeanors the question is on the
adoption of the resolution those in
favor say
I those opposed
no the eyes have it the resolution is
agreed speak on of gentleman from
Mississippi seek recognition Mr Speaker
I request the Y and
nays the Y and ns are requested those
favoring a vote by the Y and nays will
rise a sufficient number having risen
the yays and nays are ordered members
will record their votes by electronic
device this will be a 5minute
vote
e
for
no
[Music]
e
give
B
e
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
e
all
[Music]
e
for
[Music]
h
e
[Applause]
[Music]
do any member who change a
vote
[Music]
on this vote the Y are 214 and the nases
are 216 the resolution is not
[Applause]
adopted for what purposes gentleman from
Utah seek recognition Mr Speaker I have
a motion at the desk the clerk will
report the motion Mr Moore of Utah moves
to reconsider the vote on adoption of
house resolution
863 the question is on the motion to
reconsider those in favor say I I those
opposed say
no the eyes have
it Mr Speaker the gentleman from
Utah they got it I request Mr Speaker
request the Ys and nays the Y and nays
are requested those favoring a vote by
the Ys and the Nays will rise the
sufficient number having risen the Y and
nays are
ordered pursuant to Clause 8 of rule 20
further proceedings on this question are
postponed pursuant to Clause 8 of rule
20 the unfinished business is the vote
on the motion to suspend the rules and
pass HR
7217 on which the Y and nays are ordered
the clerk will report the title HR
7217 a bill making emergency
supplemental Appropriations to respond
to the attacks in Israel for the fiscal
year ending September 30th 2024 and for
other
purposes the question is will the house
suspend the rules and pass the Bill
members will record their votes by
electronic device this is a 5minute
vote
e
every
[Music]
e
one
minute
e
all members
voted does any M wish to change
vote on this vote the Y's are 250 the
Nays are 180 2/3 not being in the
affirmative the rules are not suspended
the bill is not
passed
for for what purposes gentleman from
California seek recognition Mr Speaker
by direction of the democratic caucus I
offer a privileged resolution and ask
for its immediate consideration the
clerk will report the resolution house
resolution
999 resolved that the following name
anous consent that the resolution be
considered is read without objection the
resol without objection the resolution
is agreed to and the motion to
reconsider is laid on the
table what purposes a gentleman from
Wisconsin seek Rec recognition Mr
Speaker I ask unanimous consent that the
committee on house administration be
discharged from further consideration of
H conres 84 and ask for its immediate
consideration in the
house clerk will report the title of the
resolution
house concurrent resolution 84
concurrent resolution authorizing the
use of emancipation Hall in the Capitol
Visitor Center for a ceremony to present
the Congressional gold medal
collectively to the 23rd headquarters
special troops and the 31333 signal
services company known collectively as
the ghost Army in recognition of unique
and highly distinguished service during
World War
II with that objection the resolution is
agreed to the motion Rec consider is
laid on the table is there objection or
the consideration of the
resolution for purp gentleman from
Wisconsin seek res recognition Mr
Speaker I ask unanimous consent that the
committee on house administration be
discharged from further consideration of
hcon res 85 and ask for its immediate
consideration in the house clerk will
report the title of the resolution
concurrent resolution 85 concurrent
resolution authorizing the use of
emancipation Hall in the Capitol Visitor
Center for a ceremony to present the
Congressional gold medal collectively to
the women in the United States who
joined the workforce during World War II
providing the aircraft Vehicles weaponry
and ammunition and other materials who
win the war and who referred to as Rosie
the Riveter in recognition of their
contributions to the United States and
the inspiration they have provided to
ensuing
Generations is there objection to the
consideration of the
resolution without objection the
resolution is agreed to the motion
reconsider is laid on the
table this is gentleman from Wisconsin
seek recognition Mr Speaker I ask
unanimous consent that when the house
adjourns today it adjourn to meet at
9:00 a.m. tomorrow without
objection a gentle lady from Delaware
seek recognition Mr Speaker as I asked
unanimous consent that I may Hereafter
be considered as the first sponsor of HR
793 a bill originally introduced by
representative Bill Johnson of Ohio to
strengthen the American Workforce for
the purpose of adding co-sponsors and re
requesting reprintings pursuant to
Clause 7 of rule 12 for that objection
thank
you
chair the chair will now entertain
requests for one minute speeches
the house will be in order would you
please take your conversations off the
floor purposed is the gentleman from
Pennsylvania seek
recognition Madam speaker request
consent to address the house for one
minute and to revise and extend my
remarks and the Chamber is still not in
order the chamber is still not in order
order the house will be in
order without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute thank you
madam speaker Madam speaker I rise today
to recognize uh
Danny okay the house is not in
order
would you please take your conversations
off the
floor thank you please
proceed Madam speaker I rise today to
recognize Danny cougler of Ky
Pennsylvania and Elk County Danny
currently serves as the city of St
Mary's Parks and Recreation director and
was recently recognized by Parks and
Recreation mag magzine with the national
recreation parks Association Thunder 30
under 30 award uh young uh professionals
leading the way in 2024 this award is
given to Young professionals who raised
the bar for Parks and Recreation
profession Danny was selected from a
poll of over 100 applicants and scored
on the impact of the agency's community
and service population contri
contributions to the professional
development of the field of Parks and
Recreation and for innovative ideas
programs are researched in the field of
Parks and Recreation Danny was hired as
the first yearround and full-time
director in June of 2029 in her 5 years
serving in St Mary's area she's
established a strong social media
presence and increased membership and
program participation by 40% she's also
successfully increased the city's 15
sumon program events to 45 year round
programs and events this is the first
time in St Mary's history that his
Park's director has been recogn Iz for
this award congratulations Danny on this
much deserved recognition and I look
forward to seeing continued growth in
development of St Mary's Parks and
Recreation Department thank you madam
speaker and I yield back to the balance
of my
time thank
you for what purpose does the
gentleman uh from North Carolina seek
recognition speak for consent to house
for minutes
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one
minute Madam speaker listening to
constituents is the most important thing
we can do they are telling me back home
about the burden of high cost one
constituent shared I have contined have
to continue working even after
retirement my husband cannot afford to
retire due to Rising costs I also have
to assist my mom with her bills which
puts further strain on our finances too
many find it challenging to make K meet
while caring for an elderly parent
another constituent shared my income
doesn't cover common life I can't afford
decent housing Meats at the grocery
store or basic life necess Necessities
it's harder now Madam speaker of
Congress must take every possible
measure to ensure that residents of
eastern North Carolina Rural America and
those Across America do not feel the
financial strength in their pocketbooks
and wallets thank you so much and I yell
back for what purpose does the gentleman
from Georgia seek
recognition ask consent to address the
house for one minute revise and extend
my
remarks without objection the gentleman
is recognized for one
minute Madam speaker I rise today to
celebrate James W Putney Jr a veteran
Patriot and Grand Marshal of the 2023
Savannah Veterans Day Parade Mr Putin he
proudly led the annual Veterans Day
Parade in Savannah which is dedicated to
celebrating America's Heroes his devout
service and Leadership have been evident
since answering the call to join the
United States Army at 17 years old over
two decades of honorable service
resulted in his retirement as a Staff
Sergeant at Fort binning Georgia in his
military Journey James played vital
roles as a construction and combat
engineer post retirement he returned to
his roots in Savannah transitioning to a
career at the chadam County Courthouse
where he continued his service until
2016 even in retirement James remained
actively involved in various local
organizations as he continues to
exemplify dedication and Leadership to
his community and his country
congratulations James thank you for your
service to your country and to your
community thank you madam speaker and I
Y
back for what purpose does the gentle
woman from California seek
recognition without objection the
gentlewoman is Rec reced for 1
minute Madam speaker I rise today to
celebrate the black women who won big at
the 66 annual Grammy Awards which were
held in the heart of my district best
album nominee siza came away with awards
for best Progressive R&B album best R&B
song and best pop Duo group performance
Victoria Monae became the Third Woman in
four years to take home the Grammy for
Best New Artist following Samara Joy who
won best jazz performance this year and
Megan the stallion at the age of 22
Tyler became the youngest South African
artist in history to win best African
music performance award for her Mega hit
water and Coco Jones came away with best
R&B performance still the biggest Awards
best album record of the year and song
of the year are seldom won by black
women as Jay-Z alluded to a black woman
has not won the top prize best album in
25 years I mean how much lemonade do we
have to make and with that I yield back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
California seek
recognition Madam speaker I seek
unanimous consent to address the house
for one minute without objection the
gentleman is recognized for one minute
thank you madam speaker I Rise before
the house tonight in support of the
Israel Security Supplemental
Appropriations act Israel has been our
longtime Ally and they need us more than
ever at this point with the unwarranted
unprovoked attacks that happened on
October 7 to many many innocent people
by the terrorist group Hamas and the
others that are surrounded by in their
country Israel's been under attack since
the first moment of his existence in the
40s as but even going back
Millennia Israel is a fantastic partner
on developing new technologies improved
medical Technologies improved medicines
improved
drip irrigation and improve missile
defense systems they're a great partner
with us and indeed a shining beacon in
the Middle East of as a representative
Republic unlike any other there even
Arab Israelis would rather live in
Israel than in some of those other
places because they know it's good there
they know it's right they know it's just
it's Our obligation indeed it's our
privilege to stand with Israel as an
ally in their time of great need so we
need to get over ourselves a little bit
around here and step forward and get
this work done I you'll
back for what purpose does the gentleman
from Ohio seek recognition to address
the house for one minute
and without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute uh thank you
madam speaker I rise today in absolute
disbelief and genuine disgust with what
the speaker did tonight he knowingly
allowed a bill to fail that would have
provided critical support for our troops
fighting terrorism in Iraq in Syria and
critical support for Israel he did it
because he wanted to embarrass Democrats
he also intentionally left out much
needed humanitarian aid for Palestinians
in Gaza essential support for Ukraine
and essential support for Taiwan he
chose this horrific dangerous new brand
of of partisan politics over our troops
our allies and millions in need the fact
that Palestinian need humanitarian Aid
ukrainians need to defend itself against
pu Putin and Taiwan needs support
against China is absolutely of no
interest to the speaker representative
Goldman and I attempted to amend this
bill to include aid for all three but we
were denied we will keep fighting to
fund Ukraine Taiwan and humanitarian Aid
to Palestinians in Gaza this is what the
American people want it's what our
Global Partners need and it's what this
moment
re of us I yield
back for what purpose does the gentleman
from
Georgia okay for what purpose does the
gentleman from New York seek
recognition without objection the
gentleman is recognized for one
minute Madam speaker I Rise this evening
to salute the long story career of Chief
Bobby Hughes of the East Meadow fire
department who has
been in the Nassau County fire service
for over 40 years he rose through the
ranks becoming chief of Department from
1997 to
1998 instrumental in forming the East
metal fire department Chief's
Association he's the current band leader
of the nasso county firefighters pipes
and drums who led that very band down
Pennsylvania Avenue for the inauguration
of President Trump he joined the Nassau
County fire service Academy as an
instructor in 2003 and has risen through
the ranks and this week he will walk out
of the Nassau County fire service
Academy for the last time as the chief
instructor he has made it a beacon of
Education and Training not just in
Nassau County but across the country
Madam speaker I join the nasso County
fire service in saluting Chief Bobby
Hughes and thanking him for his career
in keeping our County safe and training
the future of the fire service Madam
speaker I yield
back for what purpose does the gentle
woman from Ohio seek
recognition REM without objection the
gentlewoman is recognized for one
minute Madam speaker I Rise to pay
tribute to the the ultimate sacrifice
made by five of our nation's most heroic
men and women in
uniform each was defending Liberty in
dangerous territory and each possessed
raw courage selflessness and total
dedication to duty for the sake of our
nation each of us is privileged to live
under Liberty's umbrella because of them
special Warfare operator first class
Christopher Chambers and navy special
Warfare operator second class Nathan
Ingram were lost far from home in Rough
Waters on the Red Sea on January 11th
then 17 days later on January 28th an
enemy drone targeted Tower 22 in Jordan
the Drone operated by Iranian backed
militia terrorists wounded more than 40
US service members killing three of
America's Finest Staff Sergeant William
Rivers Sergeant Kennedy Sanders and
Sergeant Banna Moffett while all five
hailed from different hometowns they
serve together for one United purpose
Liberty defending America against all
enemies foreign and domestic these brave
Soldiers and Sailors were guarding us
against the hastening spiderweb of
terrorism and tyranny Halfway Around the
World let us pay H homage and honor each
of these young men and women for their
ultimate sacrifice may they rest in
peace may God bless
America
for what purpose does the gentleman from
Tennessee seek
recognition for one
minute without objection the gentleman
is recognized for one minute thank you
Madame
speaker the scal dugery of the speaker
of the house was on display
today he has no real interest in helping
Israel he has interest in scoring
political points with Donald Trump
and he used Israel to do that today and
he did it a month ago a month ago or so
he said he would support Aid to Israel
if it was set off with 13 or4 million in
cuts to the IRS would have only which
would have only benefited the wealthiest
tax cheats in our country to condition
aid for Israel on helping out Rich tax
cheats is Despicable and the scal dugery
today was to separate Israel from
Ukraine a country similar to Israel
that's being invaded by invaded by
Russia to try to deny its territorial
integrity and to commit a genocide just
as Hamas is trying to commit a genocide
in Israel I support Israel I also
support helping with humanitarian Aid
the people in Gaza who have been hurt
injured or killed I also support helping
Ukraine from having Russia do the same
thing and I support Taiwan I do not
support the speaker he is a man without
good faith i y back the balance of
myed for what purpose does the gentle
woman from Washington seek
recognition
requ without objection the gentlewoman
is recognized for one
minute Madam speaker I rise today In
Praise of the resilience of my community
in Southwest Washington last month a
fire broke out of one of two seafood
processing facilities near the port of
Ilwaco in my district and the aftermath
of the cakic fire the unity and support
demonstrated by the awako community has
been remarkable whereas lesser men would
have seen an opportunity for competitive
Advantage these folks chose to stand
together and see each other as neighbors
lending out crab pots to each other that
they didn't have to do U it's in I am in
incredibly grateful to come from a
community that supports each other in
the wake of a tragedy their Community
spirit is a competitive advantage that
money cannot buy and in natural
disasters cannot shake I extend my
thanks to the brave First Responders who
responded to the fire several of them
were treated for heat exhaustion uh to
their tireless effort in combating the
blaze for hours and I want to recognize
the folks in aaka who stepped up to help
local krabbers dropping off sandwiches
shipping up C pots from as far south as
California and Alaska um and rebuilding
and Recovery will take time um they will
never get back those hours of sleep or
the heartache or the monetary loss but
their Moral Moral fiber has been
revealed in a way that is durable and
will strengthen the community and is its
own reward I stand with you in your
fights and I'm so grateful for your
leadership I yield
back for what purpose does the gentle
woman from Texas see seek
recognition to address for one minute
without objection the gentle woman is
recognized for one
minute the American people might wonder
just what happened here today well first
of all the southern border deal never
got anywhere and all of the logistics
and all of the Cloak and Dagger and what
was going to be in it failed to even get
the attention of the speaker of this
house or any of the Republican members
and yet all of a sudden a unfounded
legislative initiative that was
allegedly to advocate for the needs of
the people in the mid East wound up on
the floor of the house you wonder what
we did today it wondered wound up on the
floor of the house with no conscience no
thought no commitment and that is why I
was not able to vote for it I was
willing to join an amended initiative to
ensure that all of the people that are
in need in the mid East would be taken
care of that we would have the funding
for Israel but we would have the funding
for the Palestinians and the aid that is
needed in Gaza and the ability to deal
with the crisis of death that they have
been facing that we would have the money
for Taiwan and yes that we would have
the money for Ukraine I've been to the
border of Ukraine I've seen the violence
against our children I've seen Russia
steal children I've seen parents die in
the streets it is necessary that we do
this right and that is funding for all
all of those that are in need and do it
now the gentle speak
of in a professional way for the
American people to know we care about
thetion the gentlewoman's time I yeld
back under the speaker's announced
policy of January 9th 2023 the gentleman
from California Mr Des sonier is
recognized for 60 minutes as the design
of the minority
leader
Madam speaker I ask unanimous consent
that all members have five legislative
days in which to advise and extend their
remarks and include extraneous materials
on this special order without
objection thank you madam
speaker Madam speaker six years ago I
held a special order on a subject matter
that I think is extremely important to
this country and to the developed world
the issue of growing inequality
it's been four years since covid-19
pandemic began and it's more relevant
now than ever because unfortunately it's
gotten
worse the concentration of wealth in the
United States of America is not fair
it's not American and is driving
multiple social and behavioral health
issues that more and more research
points to and
verifies the pandemic has laid bare the
Deep disparities that exist in the
United States and worsen the gap between
the richest and poorest
Americans and it has helped eviscerate
many ways American middle
class the president has tried his very
best and in the two years the Democrats
had control of both houses and the
president was in the white house we did
much to begin to change this Rising tide
of
inequality Rising inequality incurs
costs that harm us all but not just
those at the bottom of the income
distribution it hurts America next to me
is a statistical diagram of the gene
quoti that's accepted by Economist
around the world as the best statistical
measurement for inequality and you can
see just since 1993 it's steadily gone
up with the pandemic at the end I'm
pleased to have a couple of my
colleagues and friends to be here to
speak on this and I'd like to now
welcome the gentleman from Tennessee to
make a few comments
thank you so much I'm pleased to join
you because this is such an important
topic and a topic that I've talked about
for a long time uh the income inequality
in our country has grown and grown and
grown and the tax cuts of Donald Trump
which I voted against contributed to it
greatly tax cuts that gave the wealthy
much more money corporations and
individuals and did not help the poor
and didn't really help the middle class
much my district is in Memphis Shelby
County and Tipton County just north of
of
Memphis because of that I'm no stranger
to high levels of poverty and
inequality according to the 2023 poverty
fact sheet by the University of Memphis
21.4% of memphians live in poverty the
overall poverty rate for Black and
Latino memphians is almost double that
of white and Caucasian residents roughly
20 27% for Black and Latino residents
compared to 10% of whites the child
poverty rate is 32.7 a number that has
been declining in recent years due to
the child tax credits but still far too
high and we don't know how much the
child tax credits will be available to
people this coming
year in 2022 the child poverty rate in
African-American and Latino communities
was three times out of white families
30% to 10 what hope does that give Young
African-American and Latino
children the root causes of poverty
often come down to access and
opportunity childhood poverty is
directly related to the financial status
of the children's parents many young
adults in Memphis have parents and
grandparents who are prohibited from
buying houses in certain areas red
lining which is still a practice in
Memphis and has been highlighted
recently when one of the banks in
Memphis was charged with such and pled
guilty to such I
believe and that has restricted access
to home loans and mortgage protections
as well because of red lining many
families do not have the opportunity to
buy desirable
houses these policies were legal until
1968 so it's not ancient history the
impact of red lining continues as many
families were unable to build
generational
wealth now poor families need access to
services like Citywide internet
subsidized child care and support of
mortgage rates and we've tried to do
some of those things but unfortunately
it's not been a bipartisan effort mostly
an effort by democrats Tennessee is
nationally ranked as a low tax state but
that's not the case for the poorest
families the taxes are regressive it's a
sales tax dependent State and that taxes
the poor at the most regressive manner
the poorest 20% of Tennessee residents
pay a significant higher percentage of
their income in state and local taxes
than any other group in the state
low-income families are paying high
amounts of taxes while at the same time
receiving lower levels of access to
services and opportunity for economic
Mobility Tennessee remains as one of the
10 remaining states that have not
expanded medicaid that is truly
sorrowful and
immoral if Tennessee and were Tennessee
were to expand as 40 other states in the
District of Columbia have lower earning
workers would have access to Affordable
Health Care and their families would
worry less about the impacts of seeking
treatment for an
illness a billion plus dollars a year
have been turned down by our state
legislature because they don't care
about taking care of the
poor Matthew
25 talks about
healing I saw people that were naked and
I clothed them I saw people that were
sick and I fed them and I saw people who
were sick and I healed
them some people say they live by the
Bible if you want to know where my
politics are just look to the Bible well
some of those people that speak it the
most don't know Matthew
25 measures combating childhood poverty
and closing the income wealth Gap among
diverse groups are vital in my district
and hope to make more progress on the
issue I'll continue advocating for the
child's tax credit which Mr delaro is
championed encouraging tennesseans to
expand Medicaid and seeking additional
funds for education and job training and
supporting other policy to help those in
need I thank Mr doal for having the
moral courage
and the
will to bring this special order to the
people that are watching it's an
important issue and it pains me to see
our country becoming more and more
divided thank
you thank you Mr Cohen i' now like like
to recognize someone who spoke at my
first effort at this the very esteemed
ranking member of the Appropriations
Committee M Doro from Connecticut thank
you thank I thank the gentleman so very
much and I I so appreciate what you are
accomplishing here this evening is to
shine a light on the issue of poverty in
this in in in this nation and you know
we have searched and searched and
searched over decades for what is the
antidote to poverty and particularly and
child poverty um and I I'm I'm I'm often
reminded this might sound like a little
nerdy but you know the the U uh of uh
Nobel laurate um in economics ICS uh
Joseph
steetz uh once and that's just a
paraphrase what he said is that
inequality is not the result of
globalization or modernization but it
is it is the result of policy
choices and you know this body that we
are blessed to be able to serve
in deals with policy choices
which means that we can have a profound
effect
on
poverty child poverty and reducing that
in our
nation and I I I I suppose I'll just
reflect on and I pick up a little from
what Congressman Cohen said you know the
the house passed a tax bill last
week that would continue to exacerbate
child poverty in the United States
public policy
choices so I want to say a thank you to
Mr dool bringing us together tonight and
you know as I said and I so stated last
week I in good conscience I couldn't
vote for a deal that was so lopsidedly
benefiting big corporations while
failing to ensure a substantial tax cut
to middle and workingclass
families it was deeply inequitable we
have seen the greatest rise in
inequality and we have seen corporations
make super profits at the expense of the
consumer and so for me it was a mockery
of who representative government works
for who are we here to
support the bill it's massive tax cuts
for big corporations and it denies
middle class families Economic Security
that they had and we were successful
with the American Rescue plan we were
successful in having a child tax credit
and to be truthful I started out wanting
to make it permanent I was told
that can't be was too expensive that it
should be for 5 years I they said no it
can't be for 5 years well what about
about 3 years no it can't be 3 years and
they said one year and I was asked will
you take one year of course with the
expanded child tax credit $3,000 for
kids you know6 to 17 $3,600 for six
years and under monthly benefits for a
family um and so I said yes and then I
was also told at that time
Rosa once it is out there it's not going
to go away it went away
it expired and we had a
chance last week to redress that balance
and bring it back and in my view that
was a missed opportunity and once
again it is
there taken away pulling the rug out
from under Working Families middle class
families vulnerable families and driving
them into poverty once again because we
reduced the poverty rate that's what the
bill did and now it's gone from 5.2% to
12.4% hunger has risen and it went down
when we had the child tax credit and the
tax credit was the largest middle class
tax cut in history middle class tax cut
so we got billions of dollars in tax
relief for the wealthy and the way I put
it pennies for the poor that's what it's
about you know and you want to talk
about cost
benefit
returns $8 a child tax credit for every
dollar
spent and we leave a trillion doll we
cost child poverty in the United States
costes a trillion dollars every
year and we would would return 84 cents
on the dollar to the taxpayer with the
child tax credit so you know it was it's
a vast giveaway billionaires in
corporations just a couple of example
Dish Network at FedEx Salesforce t t
T-Mobile
um they pay no federal income
tax under the Trump tax law you think
about it for a sec second Netflix will
have a negative tax rate in 2024 2025
because of this tax bill that means that
they get money
back they pay no
taxes it's and then on top of that
November 2023 they announced they would
raise prices on subscribers they add an
extra $24 to $36 to what subscribers
have to pay each year to maintain
service and yet the same families will
not see a child tax credit like they did
under the American Rescue plan you know
it is absurd think about what people are
telling you my colleague in California
and my colleague in Tennessee families
today are living paycheck to paycheck
they can't something goes wrong they
can't make a $400
payment that's what's going on in their
lives they're struggling to put food on
the table to pay their health care bills
to be able to get child care you know
and groceries have
skyrocketed it's all there Child Care
skyrocketed corporate profits
though $3 trillion in
2023 they're not living paycheck to
paycheck they're going to take that
money and buy back stock which is what
they've done in the past with this thing
it was it is our families that are
bearing the brunt of inflation and high
interest rates child tax credit is the
antidote to child poverty in this
country it's a successful tool that
lifted Millions out of poverty literally
overnight so you know this is you
never what ha what's happened happened
we move forward and we will continue to
make the fight for a permanent child tax
credit in this country because we know
how successful it was we know what it
did for families and to the
naysayers who said one we couldn't raise
it to 3, or 3600 and that we could never
get it monthly well so be it we did it
and it succeeded and those who said that
people are going to dog it they're not
going to go to work they're going to buy
drugs with it they're going to you know
all by with data with data from the
Columbia School of social policy that
said people went to work because they
could afford child care and they were
able to use this money for
essential NE Necessities to buy those
groceries and you know what maybe for
their kid they could send them on a
class trip or her on the class trip
which they weren't able to do because
they couldn't afford it in the past so
it is the best thing that we can do to
improve the economic well-being and
security of American families today
let's bring back the largest middle
class tax cut in the history of this
country I can't thank you enough we need
to continue to shine the light that it
is our public policy decisions that
create inequity and inequality let's
turn that around and deal with the
policies that do turn that around and I
can't thank the gentleman enough uh for
for putting together this special order
and I can't thank you enough you know
some people accuse us on the other side
of socialism you and I who learned our
rosary and our Catholic and Christian
upbringing it was about the social
contract of St Matthews and the Bible of
to those who much is given much as
expected much as expected our our cathol
Catholicism is rich with social justice
and I look at in God we trust and this
body really needs to carry out social
justice in a way that it doesn't do
these days you can have individual
responsibility in this country and you
can have social responsibility and
that's when we've been the most
successful when Eisenhower was president
when the middle class was strong and the
union movement was strong and people got
the GI Bill and he implemented in his
own way what Franklin Roosevelt put
together that's when this this economy
was the best it was growing at over 6%
GDP year over-year and it was benefiting
everybody and I'll tell you is one of
the things that brought me to this was
as a when I was a republican restaurant
owner you would read in the trade
journals about disposable income and
this is our friend Bob reich's argument
and stig's argument if you don't have
disposable income it hurts everybody
unfortunately uh now people at places
like the Roosevelt Institute our friends
say that no more and more the top 1% is
just selling to themselves and gating
themselves off and as Thomas pickery has
said the inevitability in Western
history when you get to this level of
inequality is social disruption and
civil distress and if we don't fix it
here we'll have more of what happened a
few years ago outside this chamber amen
amen thank so much I thank my
colleague mam speaker I'm going to go
through my presentation but I do want to
thank my two colleagues uh there may be
one or two others on the way I want to
start by talking about poverty in
America I'm going to date myself again
Michael Harrington the other America uh
talked about poverty over 50 years ago
about how people in rural America were
suffering but we had the Optics of how
well people were doing um in places
where fortunate enough where many of us
live but it was Rural America that
Michael Harrington talked about and
again he was talking about the social
contract in the gospel of Matthew nearly
40 million people or 11% of the US
population lived in poverty in 2021 one
in three Americans live in a household
making
$55,000 or less and while many of them
are technically above the official
poverty line they're still struggling to
make ends meet that
$400 in unexpected
expense in 2019 the US Tri poverty rate
was double that of our peer Nations
including Germany Canada and South Korea
the relief we delivered to families
during the pandemic made a massive
impact on people's lives including the
leadership of Mr deloro the expanded
child tax credit which she me mentioned
robust unemployment insurance and
emergency rental assistance all helped
to keep families afloat during
unprecedented economic hardship and an
international p pandemic now we're
coming out of it and those funds are
going away they did their intended
purpose but now we're at a Tipping Point
the expanded child Che tax credit alone
led to stunning reduction in child
poverty this effort spare headed by my
good friend Mr lur kept 5.3 million
people above the poverty line and
between 2020 and
2021 child poverty rate plunged to
4.5% percentage points
as Mr Laura said they weren't spending
this on anything but trying to survive
provide shelter transportation and get
to work for their family and their
kids but after House Republicans allowed
the child tax credit to expire the
poverty rate for children more than
doubled from the historic low of 5.2% in
2021 to
12.4% the next year if the child tax
credit had been been been sustained at
the levels from the pandemic 3 million
additional American children would have
been kept out of poverty 3 million
wonder what they're doing this evening
according to the analysis of the center
for budget and policy
priorities while a child tax credit in
2021 in 6 months we reduce child poverty
almost half we know how to do this folks
we know what works we just have to
invest and prioritize
lifting up the most vulnerable people
amongst us and what'll they do the vast
majority will work and be honorable and
take that money for a very high return
on investment for all of
us so wealth
distribution as you can
see in this chart data from the
Congressional budget office shows that
from 1989 to to
2019 the total wealth held by families
in the top 10% in increased by
240% from about 24 trillion to $82
trillion 24 trillion to 82 trillion for
the top
10% while the wealth held by families
and other percentiles increased far more
slowly or even remain flat wealth is
skewed to the top of the wealth
distribution in the United States of
America families in the top 10% of
distribution have held more than
two-thirds of all wealth and Families in
the bottom half of the distribution held
only 2% of total
wealth I like most Americans want people
to be compensated for their creativity
for their Innovation and their hard work
but this confrontation this distribution
punishes 90% of the American public and
even higher when you look get deeper
into the numbers the total wealth held
by American families tripled from 1989
to 2009 to 20 19 but the growth growth
was far from uniform for everyone over
those three decades 30 years three
decades families in the top 10% saw
their share of wealth increase by around
30% for families in the bottom health of
the wealth distribution their share
declined from 4% to just
2% so even before the pandemic started
which we know has worsened this the
concentration of wealth among those at
the very top has gotten significantly
worse this is not about class Warfare
this is about fighting for all of
us this has been true in our history
when we went through the Gilded Age
similar thing happened we got depression
in two world wars who fought those Wars
who fought to try to get back so that
they take care of their families not the
wealthiest but most Americans who are
going out and working hard to get a a
paycheck and as Mr Laura said un un
fortunately history is repeating
ourselves and my fear is coming out of
the pandemic even with our growth even
what the president's done with
unemployment at historic lows and wages
coming up it's not enough we have to
change this and it should be in a
bipartisan analytical basis in this
house and in this
Congress what we've done has had real
impacts on those who are left out it's
not just that those at the top are
better off than everyone else as the
richest Among Us are able to concentrate
their wealth they lock away their money
in Investments that research shows never
get spent in the economy middle-income
people spend their money they consume
they go to restaurants that's better for
everybody wealthier people researched by
stiglet and others shown is generally
retained in that group of people of
people and it's even more so it's
becoming more concentrated as they spend
money amongst themselves and leave
everyone else out as inequality
increases it becomes more difficult for
those not born into privilege to climb
the ladder and build a better life
further enriching and growing inequality
this country is supposed to be Merit and
hard work and equality of opportunity
we're doing the opposite right now in
this country and it's because of
policies
here let's talk about worker
compensation this is not worker
compensation as when you get injured
although that should be better this is
Wages versus Capital Lincoln want
famously said when he first has first
addressed to Congress before the Civil
War when he was trying to hold the
country together he said wages labor in
his word and capital must always be
equal and balanced in the United States
for if Capital ever becomes dominant
we've lost
democracy despite working harder despite
being more educated despite being more
productive most American workers their
wages have grown exceptionally slowly
compared to the growth in productivity
compared to this CEO
compensation for the last 40 years the
gap between productivity and worker
compensation wages has increased
significantly Americans are working in a
more productive fashion they're working
more productively versus their
International competitors but they're
not seeing their wages go up and their
disposable income sacrifices even more a
typical workers's wage growth has lagged
far behind gains in productivity over
that time so it's the idea that if you
worked harder and you were more
productive individual Merit
responsibility is not born out in the
research and the
numbers if we look at this graph graph
we can see productivity has grown by
nearly
62% over the last 40 years but the
average hourly pay of the typical worker
grew by only
177% this Gap makes the difference
between people being compensated fairly
in their wages versus people who have
the Good Fortune to be able to invest in
capital and this is what Lincoln was
talking
about put simply workers are more
productive than ever before but are not
properly compensated for it until late
1970s workers compensation wages climbed
together with productivity but then it
began to change and diverge and it
diverges when we abandon the policies
that prioritized spreading the benefit
of growth to workers to all Americans
wealthy and middle income instead of
what we're doing now it benefited from a
strong labor
movement President Eisenhower once
famously said only a fool would try to
keep an American worker from joining a
labor union President Eisenhower said
that ceop pay another contributor to
Rising inequality is rising CEO pay this
is an ongoing issue but it's something
we've really seen balloon over the last
3 years while so many hardworking
Americans have struggled to make ends
meet during the pandemic some CEOs are
making more money than ever the average
top CEO compensation in 2022 was
25.2 million and it continues to
increase even as low-income Americans
and middle income Americans are forced
to make due with wages that year after
year affords them Less in terms of
purchasing power in
2022 CEOs were paid
344 times as much as a typical worker
the ratio of CEO to typical worker
compensation was
344 to1 in 1989 that ratio was 59 to1 in
the 50s and 60s it was even lower in
1965 it was
21:1 I've introduced the CEO
accountability and responsibility act
which would increase corporate taxes on
companies with extreme disparities
between their CEO and their workers
pay we need bold proposals like this one
to help put an end to Runaway corporate
greed and restore the balance of power
back to workers a balance as Lincoln
said stock by packs over the last 40
years tax laws regulatory change Court
decisions and new corporate behaviors
have led to shareholder first
corporations that's the corporate veil
they hide under behind where CEOs and
managers focus on share price and
investors directing corporate funds to
shareholder buy payouts corporate
profits or even corporate debt may have
once funded innovating new projects in
research and development and new hires
and worker wages or like the Germans do
reinvested in continuous training back
into community colleges and
apprenticeship programs for a lifetime
of learning for workers crafts
in the 1960s and 1970s 40 cents were
invest invested for every dollar a
company earned or borrowed but since the
1980s invested back in their Workforce
less than 10 cents of each B dollar is
invested that way instead executives are
using their profits to pay themselves
and their wealthy shareholders over the
past 30 years payouts to wealthy
shareholders have averaged
90% 90% of all corporate profits
we need Robin
Hood this has led to skyrocketing use of
stock BuyBacks when companies purchased
back their own stock from shareholders
in an open market and reabsorbed the
ownership that was previously sold to
the other investors the use of stock
BuyBacks was essentially banned except
under rare circumstances until Ron
Reagan in his security Exchange
Commission in 1982 a strategy for
companies to artificially raise their
openet Market stock prices and boost
earnings per share in 1998 1982 during
the Reagan Administration the security
Exchange Commission passed a rule that
deregulated BuyBacks allowing companies
to buy their own stock without being
charged with stock manipulation and
incentivizing them as Mr Laura said to
avoid taxes where did those taxes go not
to all of us but back to the top 1% in
their investors again Lincoln wages and
capital should be balanced The increased
stock prices do not reflect an actual
Improvement in the processes of the
company and may serve as a cover for
financial difficulties in the long run
this is why I think Republicans and
democrats should be concerned perhaps
for different reasons and motivations
but the underlying rot in our economy is
a problem as exemplified by Thomas PTY
and as he he Illustrated in his detailed
history of other economies when this
happened around the world stock BuyBacks
are just an excuse for companies to
reward stockholders and increase
dividends while avoiding employee wages
and compensation and Investments back
into their companies in investigation of
449 companies listed on the S&P from
2003 to 2012 companies used
54% of earnings to buy back its own
stock and 37% on dividends of those
earnings
The increased use of stock BuyBacks by
corporations is a way that companies pad
their profits and their mediocre
corporate management and support their
Executives at the expense of all of us
and their workers Over The Last 5 Years
the top 20 S&P 500 companies spent a
staggering 1.24 trillion buying back
their own
shares last year Chevron which is
headquartered in my district said it
would triple its budget for stock
BuyBacks from 75 billion and meta the
parent of faceback Facebook which is
near my district in the Bay Area
unveiled a $40 billion payback the
Birkins Institute looked at the actions
of 22 iconic American corporations who
alone employ over 7 million front-line
workers including the world's most
popular brands and Retail delivery and
entertainment sectors like Amazon Disney
FedEx Home Depot and Hilton in the first
two years of the pandemic they earned
even more in that time period company
shareholders at these companies grew one
and A5 trillion dollar richer while
workers got less than 2% of the benefit
1.5 trillion and 2% of the benefit for
their Workforce doesn't sound like what
Lincoln wanted and they spent nearly 40%
of their profit on stock
BuyBacks Rising shareholder payments are
linked with declining employee
compensation and increased income
inequality gains of stock BuyBacks are
also concentrated amongst the already
uber wealthy among 50 around 58% of
American households own stock that's
good but about 93% of household stock
market wealth is held by the top
10% while our investment in good strong
uh pension retirement and I'm proud to
be the ranking member
on the Health employment labor and
pension subcommittee the education and
labor committee those investments in
everybody's pensions are good and
benefit everybody the problem is most of
those Investments are going to the
wealthiest amongst us and it creates the
risk for all of us when this stops and
it's not handled appropriately for
everyone's benefit an analysis by The
Institute of policy studies showed that
the richest 10% of us households own
roughly 42.7 7 trillion in stock market
wealth and the richest 1% own 25
trillion the bottom half of households
own less than a half a trillion dollars
top
1% represents 20 owns 25 trillion in the
stock
market the bottom half holds less than a
half than a trillion dollars half a
trillion
dollars just 1% of stock market
wealth sad corporations are spending
more and more of their net incomes on
BuyBacks rather than Innovation and
Capital Improvements and compensating
their workers well for more
productivity and ultimately more
Innovation and more disposable income
for people like myself when I was in the
restaurant business to go out and
support those other jobs corporations
are spending more and more of their net
incomes or Buybacks in recent years to
enrich their Executives and their
shareholders and it comes at real cost
for their employees who have decidedly
not seen the same kind of increases in
their take-home pay or their disposable
income or their ability to go out and
consume and take care of their
kids labor unions and strikes workers
across industry are fed up with lag
legging wag wages and the benefits that
are disproportionately given to the top
1% this year more workers are
recognizing their collective bargaining
power and are walking off the job or
threatening to do so to fight for their
rights in Hollywood and auto factories
and food service across the country
workers are fighting for fair
compensation safe workplaces and job
security public approval for labor
unions as this country has skyrocketed
to over
60% Americans are waking up to these
disparities and the unfairness and the
lack of us supporting the American dream
for
everybody and rewarding hard work and
respons
responsibility and then there's the
outside influence of the uber wealthy in
elections right here in this house it's
been a big issue in the United States
and has drastically expanded since the 5
to4 Supreme Court decision on citizens
united allowing for independent
expenditures the citizens united
decision enabled corporations and other
outside groups to spend unlimited
amounts of money on elections it opened
the door to unlimited donations to super
pack
which function as a surrogate to
campaigns despite being banned from
coordinating directly with them these
numbers have
skyrocketed the impacts have been
far-reaching and continue to get worse
every election cycle billionaires alone
provided 15% of all federal midterm
election financing in
2022 according to the Brennan sen Center
analysis just 21 of the biggest donor
families 21 families each spent at least
$15 million
in one election cycle or a total of 783
million in that cycle 783 million you
see the connection between our policy
and how people get here and stay here
the effective deregulation of campaign
money and the expansion of dark money
groups who don't have to disclose their
donors are destructive to democracy
clearly citizens united has helped
reinforce the view that our government
primarily serves the interest of the
rich all of our government all three
branches all too often and that there's
no need for most citizens to participate
in
democracy all right those are the
economic social
con concerns that I have and what we're
under doesn't sound good now there's
more and more research in the connection
to you as individuals in this country to
the people who despair the so-called
diseases and deaths of Despair that are
all too frequently in rural areas in the
Midwest and the South regionally but
they're all across the country including
in the Bay area where I
represent Behavioral Health substance
abuse opioid addictions have been well
recorded by research and
writing this to me is where the tragedy
of tragedies is far beyond policy it's
the reality of how Americans have to
live that
$400 and the despair the anxiety and the
dis the distrust in this institution
that is better than this is my friend
and colleague Elijah Cummings used to
say all the time we're better than this
Republicans and Democrats so let's talk
about health the consequences of
inequality it's important to look at the
effect it has on health physically and
mentally and on the fabric of our
society economic inequality is a cause
for poor health as one re researcher
said English researchers said 20 years
ago inequality in a society are in
locked step with individual
suffering as the gap between the richest
and the poorest Americans gets larger
the health discrepancies between these
groups increase as well and they're
getting exponentially worse as health
declines it has the adverse effects on
quality of life on our economy on our
Workforce productivity and our health
care costs life expectancy in the United
States has been declining for decades
and a lot of this is directly
attributable to these diseases of
Despair it is only worsen since the
beginning of the pandemic I thought we
would come together but instead it's
gotten
worse there are Stark differences in the
average life expectancies of the
Americans at the bottom of the income
income distribution and those at the top
while the health of the wealthiest
Americans have remained relatively
stagnant while that of the poorest
Americans Has Fallen significantly where
in spite of the ACA we're still spending
the most as a percentage of GDP on
Quality Health Care unfortunately if
you're wealthy even with the ACA you're
going to get better health care and a
cast system of health care which will
cause your own life expectancy to go
down and this is a regional problem and
there's differences in a regional
problem as exemplified by a extensive
study by the KA Kaiser Foundation there
is a strong relationship with the level
of income inequality
in the percentage of population that
suffers from mental health so it's
physical health but mental health the
prevalence of anxiety
disorders impulse control disorders and
even severe mental health illnesses are
correlated to inequality chronic stress
or lack of social support increases the
risk of ill health both physical and
mental the CDC has recently highlighted
the concerning Trend not concerning
Trend the outrage of the mental health
of high school students our kids which
is worsened by the covid-19 pandemic in
2021 more than four in 10 students felt
persistently sad or hopeless and
depressed more than one in five
seriously considered attempting suicide
and particularly for young women as a
CDC and the Surgeon General has pointed
out to us this is a crisis folks for all
of us who are fortunate enough to have
kids we should be extremely sensitive to
what we're giving as a legacy and the
tragedy that we're we're committing to
the future of this country and young
people irrespective of where they live
or which party their families and
parents are registered to we should be
doing a lot more to support mental
health and Behavioral Health in this
country and that includes making mental
health care more affordable and more
accessible since the ACA in parody
there's been a 300% increase in people
seeking out Behavioral Health there's
been a similar decrease in the number of
young people going into the field
because of the exor exorbitant cost of
getting a degree talk about supply and
demand social support and social
networks are important for psychological
well-being both for individuals in this
country and there is a very tied
connection these are important
determinance of population health and
they deteriorate in unequal societies
aggressively targeting income inequality
will lead to Better Health outcomes for
more Americans the same research by uh
English experts years ago said that
again the correlation between both but
they also said the remedy was not just
more services the biggest most effective
remedy is dealing with the societal tax
and Regulatory uh impact of this
concentration of wealth and continuing
to reward
it
excuse me just a second Madam
speaker so let's talk about global in
income unequality because America as bad
as we are and we've leted on this